bonsoir nous sommes le vendredi 17 juin
nouvelle édition de votre journal de fin
de semaine journal préparé par la
rédaction voici les principaux titres il
y a trente ans disparaissait coluche
l'humoriste toujours bien présent dans
les esprits et dans le coeur des
français son nom pour toujours attaché à
celui des restos du coeur nous en
parlons avec le responsable dans les
yvelines de l'association l'abeille
sentinelle de l'environnement 7e édition
de l'opération happy days qui permet aux
apiculteurs de mieux faire connaître cet
insecte et son rôle nous sommes allés
suivre les animations proposées à la
verrière et puis comme chaque vendredi
le zapping de l'information locale que
faut-il retenir de la semaine du double
meurtre à magnanville à l'ouverture du
bac en passant par le lancement du
chantier de l'ehpad à montigny le
bretonneux
mais auparavant à l'actualité du jour
l'actualité c'est tout d'abord ce
déplacement ce matin de françois
hollande au château de versailles pour
une inauguration du nouveau pavillon
mais également en préfecture pour une
cérémonie d'hommage à jean baptiste
salvin et jessica schneider ce couple de
fonctionnaires de police tué à
magnanville le président était
accompagné du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'intérieur des familles des
victimes et des représentants des forces
de l'ordre également vous le voyez aux
alentours à la population est venue
nombreuse assister à cette cérémonie
retransmise sur l'ensemble des chaînes
de télévision moment de recueillement ou
au cours au cours duquel le président de
la république a salué deux héros du
quotidien
parce qu'ils en effet le chanteur
deux autres
j'étais là hello pleinement engagé une
service défense 2 0
bonjour il fallait vous êtes le
responsable des restos du coeur dans les
yvelines
sur ce plateau merci responsable
manifestation communiqué steve wallace
pour sable sur les différents événements
qui sont organisés je vous reçois
aujourd'hui car le 19 juin dans deux
jours maintenant ce sera un triste
anniversaire celui là de la disparition
de coluche l'humoriste le fondateur des
restos perdait la vie dans un accident
de moto trente ans après coluche et
d'unique au d'un symbole est-ce qu'il
est intouchable également à vos yeux
c'est vraiment le symbole des restos du
coeur
et à quand on fait une manifestation aux
commandes des affiches ont prennent les
gens en général préfèrent la photo de
coluche à au logo des restos donc c'est
vraiment ils incarnent les restos du
coeur il n'a pas été très longtemps avec
les restos du coeur un peu plus d'un an
mais c'est vraiment le fondateur le
l'homme des restos du coeur
qu'est ce qui a changé en trente ans aux
restos du coeur entre la création le
lancement par coluche et est aujourd'hui
le travail que vous menez s'est
énormément de choses ont changé
et puis énormément de choses sont
restées donc dans ce qui change c'est la
dimension et la diversification des
activités des restos du coeur
je pense que il y avait au départ froid
5000 bénévoles et on est 70 millions
distribués sur une ville on distribue
sur toute la france ont dû faire
personnellement voyez je donne mon cas
non j'étais là il ya j'ai commencé aux
restos du coeur il ya dix ans il ya dix
ans on accueillait 6000 personnes restos
du coeur dans les yvelines
et maintenant on n'aurait que treize
mille oui c'est le double est un soc on
vous disiez se sont diversifiées il ya
des activités qui sont aidées
encadrement qui sont proposées tout au
long de l'année et même pendant l'été
aussi la campagne d'hiver mais aussi
campagne d'été maintenant et parce que
en général la pauvreté si on est pauvre
l'hiver on est aussi pauvre l'été et
puis on a d'autres activités esther ce2
aide alimentaire on est beaucoup passé
sur l'aide à la personne c'est comment
aider les gens alors bien sûr par
l'alimentaire mais aussi par du conseil
par de l'aide par du juridique par deux
l'aide à l'emploi par du logement etc
mais il ya des choses qui sont restés
stables ce qui est resté stable c'est la
misère il y en a toujours
alors que je pense que coluche dans son
état d'esprit il pensait que ça durerait
pas longtemps son affaire donc la misère
est la fidélité de nos donateurs reste
ça c'est très important
l'image des restos reste c'est à dire on
a je pense une très bonne image d'eux
pense aussi que ces deux aux au
soutien de toute la communauté des
acteurs et des artistes soutiennent tout
à fait mais donc on a quand même
beaucoup de choses qui restent toutes
nos besoins d'univers qui change
justement c'est cet anniversaire de la
disparition de coluche marque aussi un
tournant pour les restos et pour les
ces artistes qui vous
soutiennent puisque jean jacques goldman
qui est aussi un des fondateurs
historiques aux côtés de coluche a
décidé de passer la main pour
l'organisation des vous en
pensez quoi
alors je vais vous dire qu'on thierry la
polémique l'année dernière sur la
chanson et justement je crois que j'en
vois qui a été assez touché par ça et ça
lui a fait ça lui a fait mal parce qu'
eelv avait reproché d'avoir un discours
trop moralisateur on va la jeunesse
d'une certaine et donc nous notre grande
crainte en tant que bénévole aux restos
c'était qui lâche la sphère et 10 en
haïssant l'organiser la suite donc ce
qui n'a pas été le cas on le remercie et
donc il a organisé sa suite et c'est une
suite ce qui est normal c'est à dire
mais les restos du fal dc&co lucet ya
trente ans les restos du coeur c'est
aussi un peu plus de 31 ans maintenant
donc c'est normal que les choses
évoluent c'est normal que il passe là
bas j'en viens cette image de coluche
justement quelle image avez vous quels
souvenirs gardez-vous de coluche écouter
ce micro-trottoir pas un humoriste
engagé qui avait pas la langue dans sa
poche qui voilà qu'ils disent et des
choses vraies c'était un des derniers
je trouve humoriste qui disait encore
des choses rail qui osent et les dire
bah écoutez c'est un bon deal c'est
amusant enfin bon il y avait des choses
il disait des vérités bien sûr des fois
un petit peu trop loin mais bon c'était
amusant
on le regardait quand même mais c'était
une personne mais qui a bougé toute la
société quelque part je tant que c'était
un type extraordinaire mais aussi
d'enfin aussi bien dans ses danses et
sketches que au niveau humain et c'est
le côté humain qui m'intéresse le plus
grand humoriste puis grand humaniste
aussi et puis lancement des restos du
coeur qui reste encore aujourd'hui
quelque chose de très important vient à
l'esprit c'est qu'il est mort de façon
bizarre j'ai toujours été persuadé qu'on
l'avait assassiné belle image d'un d'un
bel homme dans son coeur je crois voilà
c'est cette image que j'ai bon bien que
des fois une dérangé par son humour un
peu grinçant mais avec le temps qui est
passé je trouve que c'est lui qui avait
raison
il nous manque il manque aujourd'hui
coluche henry fall vous partagez cet
avis ce qu'il manque aussi encore un
humoriste comme lui ou en tout cas un
personnage engagé comme lidya je pense
que lille sont moins engagés six rounds
à des humoristes emploi il ya des gens
qui sont très très bien mais avec cet
engagement envers la pauvreté envers les
autres aussi fort que celui de coluche
je pense que ça n'existe pas c'est
xistera peut-être un jour mais pour le
moment ça n'existe pas je pense qu'il y
avait toute une dimension politique
aussi un véritable combat politique que
menait coluche je vous propose aussi à
présent d'écouter un autre micro
trottoir nous sommes allés rencontrer
quelques-uns des élus de notre secteur
de saint quentin en yvelines du
département des yvelines pourrait les
faire réagir et je vais vous donner
juste ce chiffre 85% des français
trouvent que coluche manque dans le
débat politique justement écouter ce
qu'en pensent nos responsables ces
propos c'est mon permis de bousculer un
petit peu je crois le discours des des
politiques à l'époque aujourd'hui on
accepte peut-être un petit peu moins
tout ça c'est bien dommage il nous en
faudrait un autre de coluche moi j'ai
énormément de respect pour lui pas en
tant qu'homme politique parce que je le
considère pas mais je considère comme un
trublion est ce trop mignon on en a
vraiment besoin aujourd'hui un esprit de
dérision
peu d'autocritique sur sur certaines
espèces culturel de ce pays sur la sur
le sur l'état sur sur les différentes
professions et de ce pays la personne de
coluche et aujourd'hui représentatif de
tout ce qui constitue notre société
existe un altruiste et et en même temps
un homme engagé dans son temps qui a
bousculé la classe politique qui a
bousculé les habitudes peu bourgeoise
pour certains et qui a permis de créer
un grand grand élan de ce revers risque
de solidarité un regard un petit peu
décalé sur sur les hommes politiques ou
la vie politique dont en ce sens est
toujours bien parce que je pense qu'il
faut aussi des gens qui qui qui secoue
un peu le monde politique et qui amène
d'autres d'autres façons de voir
d'autres façons de penser
en créant les restos aussi connu je
voulais secouer un petit peu les
pouvoirs publics son coût et les
politiques à leur montrer qu'il ne
faisait pas finalement leur mission est
peut-être à les inciter à prendre le
relais et vous l'avez dit aussi tout à
l'heure il imaginait sans doute que
jusque les restos ne durerait pas ou en
tout cas pas 30 ans est-ce qu'il ya
quelque part un échec de voir
aujourd'hui les restos perdurer et
prendre encore plus d'ampleur année
après année c'est un c'est un échec
politique est à dire c'est un échec de
notre société mais par contre c'est
quand même une réussite puisque on aide
quand même les gens et la société a
réussi à trouver un moyen d'aider les
plus pauvres et les plus démunis alors
que ce soit les politiques qu'ils
fassent ou que ce soit une association
caritative à la limite peu importe mais
vous qui êtes là justement depuis une
dizaine d'années vous imaginez comment
l'évolution est ce qu'un jour justement
les politiques vont s'emparer peut-être
plus du globe même prendre le relais
comment vous imaginez et espérer la
suite pour les restos je pense pas
personnellement je pense que là
la dynamique des associations
caritatives est là et qu'il faut pas
tout vouloir faire faire à l'état l'état
doit rester dans son rôle
personnellement c'est pas ce n'est pas
l'opinion des restos du coeur mais je le
sais mais je veux non effectivement
votre avenir
c'est l'état peut pas tout faire et il
faut qu'ils soient relayées par des
associations par des gens qui ont du
coeur aussi et qui veulent faire du bien
pour la société
il faut pas tout attendre de l'état il
faut se prendre en main et donc être
bénévole aux restos du coeur c'est
cependant en main pour aider les autres
et les bénévoles les bénévoles sont les
bienvenus encore pour cette période
estivale parce que tout à fond lui dredi
cette saison d'été vous allez continuer
à travailler voilà en juillet on a
encore pas mal de centres ouverts et on
essaye si vous voulez de regrouper c'est
à dire comme il ya beaucoup de bénévoles
qui sont pas là au point des bénévoles
qu'on remet dans un même centre pour
avoir une masse critique est en manque
de bénévoles par exemple à elancourt on
cherche des bénévoles pour elle on court
et sur les dons est ce que les dons sont
aussi encore nécessaires à ce que vous
avez besoin quel état des lieux on te
faire aujourd'hui note toujours besoin
de dons mais il y à fano nos donateurs
sont fidèles on a toujours une des dons
de façon substantielle si ce qui manque
maintenant au niveau financier c'est
avant on avait un soutien des pouvoirs
publics qui est en train de dégringoler
à une vitesse grand v puisque la région
a plus beaux de l'argent le département
a plus d'argent du coup les communes
plus d'argent etc
et quand il faut couper en quelque chose
c'est en général le social qui prend
donc aujourd'hui plus que jamais vous
avez besoin de la mobilisation de tous
de chacun merci en fall responsable des
manifestations de la communication pour
les restos dans le département des
yvelines on va terminer tout de même sur
une citation de coluche c'est pas
compliqué en politique il suffit d'avoir
bonne conscience et pour cela il faut
avoir mauvaise mémoire voilà c'est signé
mais c'est toujours d'actualité versés
auraient failli
nous poursuivons ce journal du vendredi
le ramadan se déroule jusqu'au début du
mois de juillet les musulmans pratiquent
le jeûne durant cette période mais pour
les plus démunis la fin de la journée
moment de fête se révèle difficile
l'association frères d'argile à
elancourt leur vient en aide
ce reportage tourné par fanny bourdillon
toutes les générations sont rassemblés
devant cet hôtel de coignières les
bénévoles de l'association élan
courtoise les frères d'argile propose
aux locataires de cet hôtel des migrants
de rompre le jeûne du ramadan dans notre
communauté on se doit de faire ça donc
on est beaucoup dans les chansons de
partage
et voilà donc on se rend compte que
malgré les les kilomètres qu'ils ont pu
faire ça reste on a les mêmes pratiques
on a la même façon de penser
de par notre votre religion et donc on
se retrouve entièrement dans tout ce
qu'on fait
ramadan soit c'est c'est un mois dans
lequel il faut se priver
il faut se mettre à la place des plus
démunis de ceux qui n'ont pas eu la
chance qu'on a justement de manger ce
qu'on veut de boire quand on veut et le
fait de partager sa de couper
le ramadan avec des personnes justement
qui n'ont pas les moyens qui peuvent pas
manger à leur faim je trouve que c'est
c'est juste parfait
c'est juste très bien le ramadan ou un
sacré est l'un des cinq piliers de
l'islam comme ibrahima migrants maliens
arrivé en france en 2014
ils sont 150 migrants à rompre le jeûne
chaque soir avec l'association machaal
mois s'appelle longtemps vraiment et on
n'a pas eu
elle n'a pas une association qui
viennent nous aider a paru vraiment les
remercier pour tout ce dont ils font
pour nous est vraiment et on les
encourage
on veut pas que ça reste comme ça on
souhaite que ça continue ça me touche au
coeur vraiment et sa fille c'est à nous
tous des frères donc nous ont montré que
vraiment nous aussi il n'y a pas de ya
pas une question de couleur nous ont
montré que vraiment et on est tous des
musulmans et que à moi charles live
merci moi aussi c'est ce que nous on
cherche
l'association propose aussi des colis
alimentaires à des familles
saint-quentinoise le ramadan 2016
prendra fin le 5 juillet prochain
si l'abeille disparaissait de la surface
du globe l'homme n'aurait plus que
quatre années à vivre cette prédiction
d'albert einstein est connu mais pour
autant savons-nous pourquoi cet animal
est si essentiel à l' équilibre de notre
espèce jusqu'au 18 juin
dimanche les happy days vont vous
permettre d'en savoir un peu plus la
manifestation est organisée par les
apiculteurs de france dans plusieurs
communes exemple à la verrière
dégustation et ateliers de fabrication
de bougies la journée happy days
organisés à la verrière dans la maison
de quartier du bois de l'étang
ce jeudi 16 juin a mis à l'honneur la
bei l'occasion pour les élèves de ce1 et
ce2 de l'école du bois de l'étang de
découvrir cet insecte une journée
s'inscrivant dans le cadre scolaire avec
des objectifs pédagogiques l'avantagent
c'est de venir
voir en pratique ce qu'on a étudié ou ce
qu'on va étudier en classe et de rendre
ça plus concret pour les enfants c'est
dans la découverte du monde le monde du
vivant c'est ce qu'on étudie à l'école
la chaîne alimentaire le développement
durable les enfants ont pu participer à
l'extraction du miel réalisé par
l'apiculteur référent de la verrière
gervais la journée parce que je me bats
le miel et
et découvrir les abbés moi j'aimais bien
qu'on avait scellé bouger quand on avait
goûté au ray
comme et réveille avec les happy days et
ses ateliers ludiques
les apiculteurs veulent alerter les
jeunes sur les dangers de l'extinction
des abeilles aujourd'hui 80% de nos
ressources alimentaires dépendent de
l'activité de cet insecte notamment à
travers son rôle joué dans la
reproduction des plantes
ça leur permet d'être sensibilisés au
respect de la bei et de la plante et de
tout l'environnement et surtout au
niveau des enfants c'est très important
parce que c'est l'avenir de notre
société
donc il faut les sensibiliser dès leur
très jeune âge à respecter les abeilles
et tout leur environnement
la disparition des abeilles conduit plus
de 1000 apiculteur à cesser leur
activité chaque année une mortalité
importante causée par l'utilisation des
pesticides et l'apparition de prédateurs
comme le frelon asiatique
un autre animal plus imposants celui ci
commence à connaître une certaine
célébrité en ce moment il s'appelle
hareng c'est un varan de 40 kg tout de
même qui se livrent au jeu des
pronostics est oui pour les rencontres
de l'euro 2016
il est hébergé au parc animalier de
thoiry personne n'a encore osé le
contredit hier michael et me dont il
sera peut être l'une des stars de cet
euro 2016 à ongles le var en sept ans a
été désigné par le parc zoologique de
thoiry pour pronostiquer les résultats
des matchs de l'équipe de france pendant
la compétition
en fait on lui propose trois gammes elle
avec
le drapeau de chaque équipe plus
l'option match nul et dans chaque gamme
elle donc on met une petite friandise
c'est à dire une souris donc on fait en
sorte que les gamelles soit équidistante
enfin y'a pas de gamelles plus facile à
atteindre que l'autre harangue a été
choisi pour ses mensurations de sportifs
2 m 20 pour 40 kg de muscles si on le
sort dans son enclos extérieur on peut
le voir en fait faire le tour du
propriétaire rapidement ces animaux sont
capables quand même de faire des pointes
en course à 20 km/heure après avoir
pronostiqué la victoire de la france
contre la roumanie lors du premier match
le spécialiste à sang froid avait prédit
un match nul contre l'albanie
une prédiction exacte jusqu'à la 90e
minute et l'ouverture du score d'antoine
griezmann
les bleus l'emportent finalement 2-0 la
seule chose en fait c'est qu'on avait
oublié de lui spécifier qu'il y avait
aussi les a il fallait tenir compte des
arrêts de jeu et donc lui il avait
pronostiqué match nul ce qui a été le
cas jusqu'au 90 minutes de temps
réglementaire
donc je pense qu'on peut l'excuser pour
sa part en train de corriger cette
erreur de débutant ce week-end pour le
match de la france contre la suisse
comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
de la semaine que faut-il retenir voici
le zapping de l'info locale disparition
tragique et actes terroristes
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur a rencontré ce matin les
policiers du commissariat des mureaux
c'est ici que travailler le commandant
de police tué hier soir avec son épouse
secrétaire au commissariat de mantes la
jolie par un homme se revendiquant de
l'état islamique
nous revenons sur l'attentât de
magnanville dans les yvelines une minute
de silence a été observée au ministère
de l'intérieur et dans tous les
commissariats de france en hommage aux
policiers et à sa femme fonctionnaire du
ministère de l'intérieur tués lundi soir
à magnanville 300 policiers de
mantes-la-jolie et des mureaux les deux
commissariats où travaillaient les
victimes étaient rassemblés pour une
cérémonie commune
est-ce que c'est comme le reconnaît
c'est aussi peut-être un début d'été
donc c'est vraiment ce que représente
notre public
faut pas oublier aussi que des shows
cible des communautés notamment les
juifs
on l'a vu notamment les caricaturistes
on l'a vu aussi avec charlie et pour ce
qui est effectivement de la communauté
gay notamment à orlando beaucoup de
médias pas seulement français mais dans
le monde entier ou un peu passé sous
silence qu'il y avait effectivement donc
des gays c'est sûr que c'est plus facile
de dire je suis charlie sur les réseaux
sociaux que je suis gay où je suis
effectivement solidaire d'un attentat
donc en direction des gars et c'est un
petit peu nous ce qui nous heurte parce
que même quand on parle donc de l'uefa
qui aurait pu effectivement faire des
minutes de silence pour la tuerie donc
d' orlando
cinquante trois personnes blessées 49
morts et bien l'uefa dit non il n'y aura
pas deux minutes de silence et ça c'est
un petit peu détestable
les fresques du vélib ou prennent forme
trois premières maquettes ont été
présentés lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs de plaisir le week-end
dernier les témoignages des habitants du
vally bout ont permis aux artistes de
réaliser ces esquisses des fresques
reflétant la mixité culturelle et
sociale du quartier
ça représente on va dire tout toute
identité toute personne ça va changer
l'image surtout du quartier ça fait six
ans que je me bats sur ce dossier avec
des hauts et des bas c'était pattes
c'est pas toujours évident de réunir des
partenaires de répondre
un appel à projets d'être retenue de
trouver des financeurs c'est une grande
satisfaction
il ya aussi un côté très très émouvant
lundi 13 juin le maire de la commune a
posé la première pierre en compagnie du
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier
le futur établissement du groupe korian
accueillera 80 ils résident 55% des cas
de maltraitance et un proche c'est à
dire les enfants
le conjoint ou le reste de la famille
une augmentation des violences en
institution a été constaté par
l'association ces deux dernières années
une campagne de sensibilisation est
lancée par le département en direction
du grand public
un douzième candidat s'est déclaré pour
la première de la droite et du centre
qui sera voté le 20 novembre 2016 c'est
le député les républicains henri guaino
ancien conseiller spécial de nicolas
sarkozy à l'elysée il a annoncé lundi sa
candidature à la primaire en vue de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 à
laquelle il concourt à directement s'il
ne réunit pas les parrainages c'est le
troisième député des yvelines à avoir
officialisé sa candidature assez stressé
voilà mais bon on va essayer de
de faire ça bien ça je suis détendu mais
en fait j'ai peur de tomber sur un truc
où j'ai pas du tout d'inspiration donc
voilà c'est ça qui fait peur mais sinon
nous donner un bon et on fait une impro
et l'armée sur la cession avec périscope
le théâtre d'impro prend un sérieux coup
de jeune a besoin d'une grosse
installation deux téléphones portables
un fond noir et les suggestions des
spectateurs suffisent le réseau social
permet de filmer et de diffuser en
direct avec son smartphone afin de
toucher un grand nombre de spectateurs à
travers le monde entier qu'est ce qu'on
entend par une bonne note
ça c'est une question limite
philosophique une bonne note ça pourrait
être entre
elle est très et 15e j'espère la voir
mais c'est c'est très peu probable parce
que ça demande énormément de travail et
même si je l'ait peut-être fournis je
sais pas si je pourrais l'avoir
j'ai trouvé que blanche neige était un
compte absolument moderne parce que de
nos jours avec les projets de les
progrès de la de la science de la
médecine la diététique la cosmétique
aussi ça amène de cette condition cette
situation qui peut faire naître un
problème de deux conflits autour de la
séduction
voilà pour l'essentiel de la semaine et
concernant le drame survenu à
magnanville les sénateurs ont eu
l'occasion d'interpeller le gouvernement
lors des traditionnelles séances de
questions et catherine tasca sénatrice
ps des yvelines s'est adressé au premier
ministre en lui demandant comment il
entendait protéger les forces de l'ordre
manuel valls a rappelé que les moyens
avaient augmenté pour les prochaines
années déjà la création de 1680 emplois
supplémentaires déblocage de 425
millions d'euros sur trois ans il a
appelé une nouvelle fois à l'unité on
reste dans les réactions de politique
elle se sont multipliées cette semaine
autour du terrorisme et je vous propose
d'écouter à présent jean frédéric
poisson député des yvelines président du
parti chrétien démocrate est candidat à
la primaire de la droite et du centre
voici un extrait de ses propos jean
frédéric poisson est président il
s'occupe d'une commission à l'assemblée
chargée d'étudier le financement de
déchets il sera l'invité du prochain
café politique ce que nous observons
comme beaucoup d'autres connaisseurs du
sujet c'est que les financements ont
tendance à se réduire que les
financements de masse représente malgré
tout environ sans doute un milliard et
demi d'euros par an ce qui fait beaucoup
d'argent
et troisièmement il ya un décalage total
entre le financement et l'argent qu'il
récupère neige sur place sur son
territoire du califat autoproclamé d'un
côté et les très petites sommes d'argent
qui sont nécessaires pour réaliser un
attentat ici tué deux policiers
magnanville qu'est-ce que ça ça ne coûte
pas d'argent
le bataclan ses 30000 euros de
l'attentât de l'aéroport brussels ses
vingt-cinq mille donc entre un milliard
et demi d'un côté puis 25000 et 30000
qui peuvent facilement être collectés
ici il ya un décalage qui là encore nous
met en situation de difficulté pour
appréhender ces flux financiers modestes
et et piste est un peu mieux
et prévenir autant que possible les
attaques jean frédéric poisson invités
du café politique vous l'avez vu avec
cet extrait première diffusion samedi à
partir de 19h sur notre antenne et
aussitôt en replay sur notre site pour
terminer ce journal quelques-uns des
sujets que nous allons développer à
partir de lundi nous reviendrons une
nouvelle fois sur la primaire à droite
avec un autre candidat l'ancien premier
ministre françois fillon il sera dans
les yvelines pour un meeting à
aubergenville le 22 juin la veille
nous célébrerons à la musique pour on
l'espère l'arrivée de l'été pour la
première fois le conseil départemental
va ouvrir le domaine de madame elisabeth
à versailles pour l'organisation de
concerts et enfin les soldes
elle débute le 22 juin à 8h bien qu'elle
soit moins populaire que par le passé un
français sur deux elle les considère
toujours comme incontournable nous
verrons comment se préparent également
lé et commerçants dans un instant vos
idées à sorties et loisirs avec michael
et demi d'euros le 7 8 week-end
rendez-vous à lundi 18h en direct pour
le journal 19 heures pour la première
rediffusion et d'ici là n'oubliez pas de
me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux très
bon week end